quanta gioia di vivere siccome l'ultima
volta sono riusciti a fare quella questa
cagata livello pre start che mi ha
distrutto due diottrie facciamo quello
più difficile ritratto sono arrivato già
il 32 per cento l'ultima volta
incredibile però probabilmente oltre il
38 non andrò mai però proviamoci
ragazzino non vi prometto niente su sta
roba è però le fate che non mi ricordo
neanche più come alto livello
[Musica]
mi sento già la chiatta che entra in
circolo
porca eva ecco posto non dover fare chi
debba dir niente niente non riesco a
farne ma neanche per sbaglio le scale a
centrare il punto
ma porca vacca adesso agli edifici e
geometri lascia niente
io porto sul canale i giochi in cui sono
più legato in assoluto un genio del
marketing dello youtube inc
[Musica]
poi macchina
e no
[Musica]
stava cascando malissimo
si no
[Musica]
ma vaffan
tua madre morta ieri in autostrada ma
dai legami chiara non è non è difficile
quella parte lì porca vacca dai ce la
posso fare non è difficile lo giuro
mi sono fatto prestigiosi veramente io
ho fatto la comunione regala anche la
crisi ma che cosa lo fate se poi gioca
sta roba porca eva porca eva quanto è
terrificante st parte stiamo pure
riuscendo e quello che mi sorprende il
messaggio
[Musica]
fa male qui che fanno un male in qui
sì
qui
porca vacca ma quanto diffamano la mamma
ma tu sei scherzo ma voi state veramente
primi state prendendo per il culo
e infatti pil e na roba in mare ma è mai
indicibile ma come fa un essere umano a
passarola ma già per arrivare dove sono
arrivato mi sono sorpreso di me stesso
cioè mi sembra roba incredibile quando
arrivò lire cioè della serie sono
veramente io che sto giocando però noda
è mica una certa diventa fattibile ma
dai
c'è un limite a tutto ragazzi sul serio
mi do pure ruttare non fosse spesso col
play crederci come play
no no
[Musica]
lui
ma dai ma perché sono stupido come
persona di voi
[Musica]
cosa succede aiuto aiuto
cosa avete il mio zio riga terrificante
qua
no no ce l'ha la scritta la scrit
ma la scritta era un ostacolo ma che ne
so ma mai più arrivero lì ma mai più un
miracolo divino 120 alcuni pezzi non
sarà anche come ho fatto a farli sia
assurdo già arrivare qua è incredibile
per me era certo gioco ed inferno aiuto
[Musica]
non ho mai visto mi rovino il vino vino
la vita mi rovino l'anima per professori
subito sporco dentro mi devo grattare il
naso madonna che prurito
porco demonio a fastidio madonna dio
mente che sta registrando ragazzo
[Musica]
no
ho trovato questa posizione estra comoda
dello stacco sì col non si vede mango
l'ipad che ciò tra le gambe che non è
male mi sembra riguardo al minucciano
ogni tre secondi però in realtà sta
guarda all ipad non è come sembra
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
maledizione la vita perché per questo li
porca vacca morta vai
[Musica]
vado a farmi uno yogurt con i semi di
girasole che mi calmo va muller fate
l'amore con la madre di chi ha inventato
sta roba qua mi fa parlava infatti
appare chiaramente oggi non è giornata
di giochi brutti media non potevo uscire
si opti quanto ci mette uscire giusti
che palle che attesa
[Musica]
sì
si va forte ma parole del papa sono
stronzi andava bene ma vanno cagato così
insensibili non ci siete diventati col
tempo spero
no dai a sarà veramente l'agar agar agar
agar basta basta non ne posso più ora
che va veramente ultimo tenta un ultimo
questo è l'ultimo tentativo l'ultimo che
faccio poi basta veramente dove mi fermo
mi fermo anche all'inizio se perdo
[Musica]
siete voi
ha detto
[Musica]
no
tutti voi
noi
si no
[Musica]
lui
la prof
ecco
[Musica]
no